en 1952 isabel llegó a kenia como
princesa y se fue cinco días después
como reina
ese fue su segundo viaje al continente
el primero fue en 1947 cuando visitó
sudáfrica allí dio un discurso en su 21
cumpleaños
expresando su dedicación a la como
declaró ante todos ustedes que toda mi
vida sea larga o corta estará dedicada a
su servicio y al servicio de nuestra
gran familia imperial a la que todos
pertenecemos
poco después de convertirse en reina
isabel segunda tuvo que enfrentarse a un
imperio que cambiaba rápidamente a
medida que las colonias de áfrica se
independizaban y se convertían en
repúblicas incluso a una edad temprana
la reina utilizó su encanto e influencia
para conseguir que las nuevas naciones
independientes
permanecieran dentro de la commonwealth
ghana fue el primer país del áfrica
subsahariana en obtener la independencia
y en
1961 la reina visitó el país a pesar de
que algunos políticos decían que no era
una buena idea en ese entonces ghana
atravesaba un momento difícil con el
presidente kwame nkrumah volviéndose
autoritario e inclinándose hacia la
unión soviética pero fue durante esta
visita cuando la reina y tu historia al
bailar con el hombre que la sustituyó
como jefe de estado de ghana fue un
momento enormemente simbólico una mujer
blanca una reina bailando con un hombre
negro que era súbdito del imperio
británico
el viaje sentó un precedente para otros
países africanos y contribuyó a cambiar
el curso de la historia
bruma dejó a un lado sus planes de
abandonarla como webs y eeuu a cabo
financiando parte de la presa de acoso
mvo en el sureste de ghana